頭痛
そうまた小塚くん
応援が効いたんですよ
その公園にちょっと教育を問うは無視あるして工事中
工事中でん今公演を作ってるらしい後駒田入れないっぽいので
まだいけませんでした公園でね何かしようと思ったんですけどできなかったので
ちょっと今の僕についてちょっと話そうと思いますとりあえず実は今ですね
大学4年生の
8多分
このまま行くと学生最後になるんですよねあー中3大学は留年してねーからな
イギリスに半年間留学入っててちょっと判断ので半年休んで9曲ですよ私休んで卒業だ
1年遅れた状態なんで俺あれだぞ全く対応としたりしてないから
23個ぐらい落としたけど一応ストレートで卒業なんだよねーとか言うだよ
理由とかして
ね大学卒業が何にしようかと思ったんですけども
性格 youtube やってるんでなんか映像関係の勉強しようと思ったんですけど
も
とりあえずは大学を卒業してからは仕事というか何かちゃんとこ
学生はもうとりあえず今年で最後にしようと思ってます
なので何だろうな獅子ず今年の夏が学生最後の夏って
感じなんですよ
ちょっとねうーん
ちょっと今年の夏は特別というかね
思い入れのある夏にしようかと思いましてなんかね学生追われていくと寂しいですよ
今までさ学生という名を使って何か割とね
こう自由に来ちゃらんぽらんとなんか自由に適当にやっていたわけなんですけれども
それも
今年でおしまいです別にだからっつってなんか人生が終わるわけではないんですけども
とりあえずねお腹ヘラヘラしてるの
まあ
渡部卒業してもヘラヘラしてると思うんですけどもなんかねえ
生最後と言うと複雑な気分なんですよか始め今何してるのとか言われるんですけども
今学生をしています学生をしてるんですけども安易が
後事業を2つ取りはもう卒業できるんでホンダの学校にほぼ行かなくていいんですよ
意外と日にねぇ剣頑張ってたから単位はたくさんとったんですよ
卒業はないじょ余裕です
ちゃんとできればいいん
やっぱりボケがすごいあのこれもレンズ違うやつです
商店いい単焦点レンズとめちゃくちゃボケるレンズ使ってますはいという疑念
ちょっと訳がわからない動画になったと思うんですが雨にある漫画を持ったことを
しゃべるだけの動画です
夏ってな一度仕切りしか来ないから3市町きりしか来ないのに学生最後の夏だからマジ
で
ジョブ
人生で一番の夏にしたいと勝手に思ってるんで始まったね
夏
def